our very own confidence cooking coach
nanny bubby is back in studio thanks to
chapman automotive of course the
sponsors of this segment today we are
learning how to make pink glow pineapple
carpaccio oh a mouthful that is and it
rhymes too and pink glow pineapple is a
brand new fruit it is it's a brand new
fruit
only i i know let's pull it out okay it
comes from crosstalk
in this beautiful box wow with a little
tag that says pink glow pineapple on the
side it says the jewel of the jungle
your treasure
and you open it up and you pull out this
pink pineapple big deal everybody and if
you will just notice
what is missing on this pineapple the
the tall little ring the top is missing
and here is the reason why these are so
rare that if they send them with the
tops they would be missing an ability to
replant it so most of these are
replanted
by taking the top off just putting them
right into the earth and they grow
another pineapple tree that is
incredible so this is
rare and lovely they've only been on the
planet let me just say they've only been
on the planet five years wow it is the
earth's newest fruit and they've only
been sold retail for two years and you
can only get it online right
calm okay exactly that's good to know
now this recipe uh the pink pineapple
carpaccio was taught to me by tasha ann
powell okay from picture pal which is a
food tour organization that is specific
to france
italy
and morocco and this carpaccio is a
moroccan recipe so okay ready and
carpaccio i think beef carpaccio or yeah
right okay so this is
pineapple carpaccio
we're starting first with making a
simple syrup and you do that by equal
parts
sugar and water
start bringing it to a simmer whisk it
in and i'll let you put in a teaspoon of
the cardamom okay there you go gonna go
real fast
and then the cinnamon there you go and
then chili peppers chili peppers now i'm
going to let you do this because i love
teaching you something new you've never
worked with a microplane are you
right-handed yes okay so you're just
going to do this get all of that doesn't
it get all of that in there just a
little bit and then just pop it right
into there we're going to be bringing
this to a simmer i'll put in the lime
juice while you're doing that so here
comes the wine that's enough yeah i'm
going to go ahead now turn it up oh
that's okay turn it upside down and pop
it in there you go isn't that great
okay so this will come to a simmer and
what you'll do is you'll let it thicken
so it comes to about half its
consistency i mean the smell is just
amazing it smells like wellness so here
is the key to making carpaccio okay now
in some cases they use meat slicers but
you don't have a meat slicer at home and
neither do i you surely don't surely she
surely does surely as a student i do not
we are using instead what's called a
mandolin and the way that these are done
is that you absolutely want to make sure
whether it's beef carpaccio fish
carpaccio or pineapple carpaccio is put
it in the freezer for about 30 minutes
before you slice it okay and that's how
you get those paper thin slices that
hold together so it's not carpaccio if
the slices aren't super thin right so
here we go and i put this fork in just
kind of jerry rigged it in order to be
able to slice there we go let's see
let's see what we have
yeah it is whoa
okay i think we have enough to make a
great plate perfect okay so we'll put
this over here okay okay so i also noted
that we're going to be using edible gold
today did you see that and you can get
edible gold if i know you've never heard
of it um we'll put that down and you can
hold this how's that perfect and edible
gold can be found and i'm leaving this
out there because they're going to call
and ask where do you get edible silver
and gold easy leaf products dot com easy
leaf products.com so boom here's a there
you go so here's how it comes it comes
into this leaf right here we're just
going to simply turn it upside down and
onto the plate we're putting it in the
middle you put a little bit of that just
around the edge that fell off this is a
great way to make your dish just shine
yes so here we go we going to start with
let's see are you able to get that or
this might be in the way look how nice
and beautiful 30 seconds
oh no i know i know oh no okay come back
we got this
okay oh my gosh all right there we go
really quickly just one line and what's
great about carpaccio is that it is a
very simple dish too okay there is the
mint there is the
pomegranate which is very moroccan
and now your simple syrup with all the
herbs in it just sprinkled right around
and if i might i was going to do this
really quickly oh we're getting
with me oh my gosh great great wait wait
wait here we go it's not going to hold
we don't have the time
happy birthday to us thank you to us
happy birthday dear
happy birthday to us there we go i get i
get pink little pineapple carpaccio for
my birthday i am happy okay there you go
wow there you go
yeah try this one there you go taste it
thank you for joining us thank you
chapman thank you to everybody at
channel 8 for always being here and uh
helping nanny bubby spread love like
butter check out nanny bubby's kitchen
and garden on social media and online at
nannybubby.com we also want to thank
chapman automotive again for sponsoring
this segment this is delicious kendall
welcome to you i'm glad you love it
happy